mais là messieurs bonsoir la rumeur
courait depuis plusieurs semaines cette
fois ci c'est fait christine villemin a
été arrêté cet après midi et inculpés
par le juge jean michel lambert de
l'assassinât du petit grégory c'est à
dire de son enfant ce soir on a mille
mains pas sa première nuit à la prison
de metz
le film de cette journée et les raison
de l'inculpation de christine villemin
par notre envoyée spéciale à epinal
marcel trillât encadrés par les
commissaires andrieu ego razzie de la
police judiciaire de nancy et leurs
hommes feyssine villemin était encore
sans entraves lorsqu'elle s'est
présentée devant le juge lambert au
palais de justice d'epinal il était
16h30
deux heures plus tard elle était inculpé
d'homicide volontaire sur la personne de
son fils grégory et écroué à la prison
de metz inculpés et non pas coupable
il n'est pas superflu de le rappeler
dans cette affaire si fertile en coups
de théâtre et en accusation sans preuve
or les preuves manquent toujours je
lambert ne dispose pour l'instant que
d'une troublante convergence de
présomptions la contre expertise
graphologique déposé ce matin sur son
bureau et qui confirmerait les
ressemblances frappantes entre
l'écriture de christine villemin est
celle du corbeau mais d'autres
graphologue avait accusé bernard laroche
autre expertise déposée ce matin celle
des chimistes qui aurait établi une
ressemblance frappante entre les
cordelettes retrouver chez les villemin
et les liens qui ligotaient le petit
grégory et puis il ya les incertitudes
de l'emploi du temps de christine
villemin
à l'heure du crime et les témoins qu'il
aurait vu que c'est une lettre à l'heure
où le corbeau expédié la sienne les
présomptions des suspicions mais encore
une fois aucune preuve formelle
je veux donc espérer cette fois que la
justice pourra suivre son cours
sereinement et que chacun se gardera de
toutes conclusions trop hâtives
oui puis je viens d'apprendre que jean
marie villemin a été transféré de la
prison de saverne à la prison de nancy
je vous rappelle qu'il est inculpé pour
l'assassinât de bernard laroche
et puis à propos de l'inculpation de
christine villemin ce commentaire de m
garot l'avocat de christine villemin et
de jean marie villemin
il n'y a aucune preuve matérielle entre
christine les pressions d'une certaine
presse ont été plus fortes que les
procès verbaux de gendarmerie je
rappelle que les gendarmes qui avaient
mis en cause initialement bernard
laroche avait ensuite s'était dessaisi
du dossier
oh
ofi du srpj